when you're building this webpage and
you've got a moat content and a banner
across the top and a banner across the
bottom and ads down the side content is
being fetched from different servers to
fill in all chunks of that page these
might be ads for example and if the ISP
can replace one of these with the ISPs
ad server then they've essentially
kicked out this ad network from the
process so that ad network thinks that
they're serving up an ad but the ISP is
replacing an ad with their own ad which
means the ad networks kind of paying for
something which they're not getting it
also means that the ISP is getting the
benefit of this very popular page for
example this might be the CNN front page
for example and this is P ad is now
being asserted there in place and so
everybody who's go to CNN web page
they're getting the ad that the ISPs
inserted going in so surely that put few
people's noses out of joint won't it yes
yes it will and it's something that's
yeah I I guess it's not really
considered good practice but something
that does happen the problem with a lot
of the original protocols used for the
web is that they're completely insecure
so they're neither confidential so all
the data that you're transferring can be
seen but observed by anybody who happens
to be in them able to sit in the network
and see that they are completely
unauthenticated even if you encrypt all
the data so that nobody can tell what it
is as it's being transmitted and
received you might not have any idea
that you're sending it to the right
person or receiving it from the right
person so that there's no authentication
either and as a result of this it's
possible to do a whole variety of
attacks on traditional web protocols
where you can intercept communication
for example and maybe insert bad data
into that that sequence of exchanges or
you could to redirect somebody to a
different web site and they thought they
were getting to because there's no the
person who's making the communication
the person is running the web browser
has no way to check that they're
actually getting it from the real site
that they thought and TLS kind of fixes
a lot of that by providing means both to
encrypt the data in the communication
but also providing means to authenticate
the sender and receiver so that you can
tell that you're actually getting into
the website you thought you were getting
it from I remember doing a video where
we looked at how a website is
just what you get from one page is made
up of all sorts things so does that very
complicate thing that complicates things
in the sense that when you get the
original page the original page will
just saw the first page that you go to
the URL you go to will have some kind of
base page and then you'll fetch the data
from that web server and your web
browser will start rendering our data
and putting it up on the screen for you
and it will then be filling in holes in
that data which have references to other
objects on the web so they might be
simple images they might be complex sub
pages they might be adverts from an
advertising site they might be also all
sorts of things that are necessary to
fill in the gaps in that base page and
because of that sort of complexity of
that structure you end up relying on a
lot of other servers all doing the right
thing and all behaving appropriately and
if those servers are in networks which
are not the network to which you're
initially connected you might be
fetching data from all over the planet
in order to build that the page that's
going to be rendered and because of that
just because of that complexity map
diversity there becomes a lot of weak
links or a lot of potentially weak links
in that if you use TLS to encrypt all of
those connections you've got a better
chance and authenticate all of those
connections you've got a better chance
that data you're getting is the data you
intended to get and not the data that
somebody who was in the middle of one of
those networks inserted you've got the
symbol for a web browser
let's go old-school yeah this is your
web browser and you've got the first
server that you go to
I've got no imagination today server com
so you're going to make a connection to
that server and send a request and
you're going to get some page that comes
back and then you might have more
requests that go to that server you
might have requests that go to other
servers out there as a result ask this
server connections is one and then you
might have a bunch of other requests
that all get sent out to a bunch of
different networks possibly multiple to
the same and then you have a bunch of
things come back and images come back
and had to come back and this is what
happens as the page is slowly slowly
being built if you look at a web page
where either this hasn't been fully
thought through or maybe you're
accessing from a network that's a bit
slower than normally you might see this
happening so as the page renders things
move around a bit because it's a bit of
being filled in as the responses come
back from the different servers causing
everything else to jump up out of it
the problem is that any of these
connections of these are all using HT
P then there's no way for the browser to
verify that the data that's coming back
here is actually coming from this server
it could be coming from somebody else
instead and there's nothing inherently
that stops that being the case there's a
bit of work that needs to be done for
this attack to happen if this guy just
start sending bad data to the browser
and the browser is not expecting it the
browser would have been it nothing will
happen that the operating system will
just bin it but if this guy happens to
be able to observe this initial request
going out it might be able to observe
enough of the information there in order
to be able to insert data before the
response comes back from the real server
for example which could significantly
confuse things so this is the sort of
attack that will happen if you've got an
isp doing this kind of thing for example
so if your network provider chooses to
try and insert data onto the webpages
you're visiting then instead of you
getting the data that comes back from
the server what happens is this is all
going through the ISPs network it's
simplistic to say we just ask a server
for stuff because there are all sorts of
computers in the way on yet so these
packets that are flowing to make the
requests and the packets of the flowing
come back the response each of those
packets could be manipulated and
interfered with in some way and so what
can happen is that the the packets come
through here and then the ISP redirects
those packets to the ISP server and then
you see these responses coming back for
the nice P server and there was no way
for the originator of the request to
tell that that was what they expected to
happen for at least in the default case
instead of HTTP if you have HTTPS which
means that you're using the protocol
called TLS then what happens is that
there's an initial connection setup that
happens and so the ISP tries to redirect
these connections down there then there
will be an exchange that takes place
before the request is sent which means
that this computer here will attempt to
authenticate that computer there and it
will say no no that's not the right one
that's not what I expect so HTTP is
basically HTTP being carried on top of
layered over TLS which is then layered
over TCP normally speaking HTTP is
layered on top of tcp/ip
then what happens is with HTTP is if I'm
going to example.com I expect to get the
right
yak for ya so in fact what roughly
speaking you have an exchange of
certificates so the connection is made
and then pass the initial negotiation
that happens is that this server
presents information to the client
saying this is some information that I
could only have if I have access to this
certificate so I go and check it against
that certificate and the client will say
ok so I now need to go and find a
certificate to check it against there's
actually a hierarchy that will sort of
bubble back up to the top so you'll your
server might be down here and your
clients trying to access that and they
may have to check against multiple
points to keep checking that it's been
signed with the right certificate till
you get back up to the top and at the
top that certificate will be something
that's actually embedded inside the
browser and so the client can then check
against that which it already has and
it's already it doesn't have to rely on
anything on the network to get that it's
got that built in and if that checks out
then it knows that this sequence of
signatures has been validated at every
step and so it can trust this server to
be that server that it claims to be the
fundamental thing behind all of that is
the idea that this server can only
respond can only provide that
information if it has access to this
secret and that secret has been signed
by another secret and so you go back up
the chain of the secret signing or the
secret signing on the secrets to get to
warm in the auditing you at the point
you're there then you can be certain of
that chain it's not infinitely it's a
trust thing isn't it based upon somebody
you know you trust who they trust who
they trust it is yeah and ultimately you
get back to one that's built into the
browser itself one of the things that
happens then it becomes a big deal when
another entity is allowed to put another
certificate inside the browser so you'll
have a bunch of these that are embedded
in the browser for these root
certificates and if you've got one of
those routes difficut it means you can
sign other people's certificates and
they can then sign other people's
certificates and so you can end up if
you let you know did you sign the rom
it's difficult for somebody they can
then go and create stuff which they
won't say ok to when they shouldn't I
think we touched on this briefly when we
did a superfish video a Tom Scott but
what's happening now with this is P then
well so what's happening for example is
you can have there's so there's a
service called let's encrypt that
started up where you can get your own
certificates relatively lightweight
fashioned from this which is a good
thing in many ways because it means it's
easier for people to do this on the
other hand
the things they had to do in order to
make that service really viable was get
their root certificate embedded in all
these browsers and so that means that
these certificates no longer pop up and
throw an exception so I don't know where
this one comes from it's valid you have
a you have a problem a similar problem
in a without involving let's encrypt
where you just have people doing what
are called self-signed certificates so
the certificate that gets checked
essentially doesn't have this hierarchy
it's just a certificate unto itself and
so the browser looks at that and goes
well this is signed by itself
essentially so it's signed by the same
entity that's issued a certificate which
means that on the one hand this is going
to be an encrypted connection so it's
all going to be fine and it checks out
as far as I know on the other hand I
haven't been all to ask anybody else to
verify this for me so it's still just
you claiming to be whoever you claim to
be and I've got no other way of checking
that out which is why a lot of browsers
and increasingly browsers will start to
shout at you and say this is a
self-signed certificate do you really
want to trust this watch your back yeah
because there's no there's no external
validation but that actually the
entity's done that really is the entity
who says that they so there so you can
have this sort of thing happening you
can actually have this kind of attack
where you not applause yeah attack where
the browser is trying to get to the
server the ISP server is used to
intercept that can happen with TLS as
well because you can essentially have
the connection gets rebooted down to the
ISP server and then the ISP server will
manufacture a certificate with which to
claim ownership of the address of the
name that the client is trying to access
and if it presents that back and the
client believes for example in
self-signed certificates or the ISP
controls enough of the chain of trust
that they can produce a certificate for
the ice that the clients browser will
trust then at that point this server to
all intents and purposes even on HTTP
connection appears to be the right
server so one piece of advice for your
humble user out there who's got all this
happening behind the scenes what would
it be a humble user out there
shields up on your browser right listen
to the warnings so if you've got other
things near padlocks are not being
closed and they should be or bars in red
or you've got a warning pop-up saying
this is a self-signed certificate II
really sure don't just click yes
except everything right it's trying the
system is trying to tell you something
unfortunately a lot of the time it's
telling you something which is
irrelevant or is telling you something
you can do nothing about
so it's either visit the site or don't
go to the site but it is actually trying
to tell you something and you should pay
attention to it you might just get in
for habita clicking yeah or whatever and
you shouldn't really do that if you
really care then you pay attention to
that and you don't go through when it
systems warning about something you
don't go through that the problem is
that a lot the time those warnings are
either irrelevant or you can do nothing
about it other than stop whatever you're
doing which is often not acceptable to
people is it is there a way you could
circumvent any of those problems I mean
private browsing or anything like that
private browsing to stop it attempts to
stop information leaking between
browsing sessions but fundamentally
private browsing or not you'll go into
the website and it's the wrong website
and it's got malware on it then your
browser is still going to get owned
right or you know if you type in your
bank details and you type them into the
wrong website then you still type them
into the wrong website private browsing
doesn't help with that
have another one with its state and the
operations around it and this can
represent the other paddle so we've got
two objects a world on your everyday
physical experience let's get the Google
glass in there there it is I think I'd
be tempted to position it a bit further
along the line here